from luke canard to luka doncic luca 46
14 assists kawhi
pg 50 points and 19 assists
here's luca in the losing effort what do
you believe this team needs to do to
take the next step forward whether it be
personnel wise or something different to
go into next season
i think that that's a question you
should ask
the guys that make the team right i'm
just
a player here you know but we gave
everything
in the i think we played great
uh we gave everything i'm really proud
of this team
uh obviously i hate losing we hate
losing but
i'm proud of my team rachel nichols
hey lisa um now that you've had a second
run through the nba playoffs what have
you learned about
playing in this league at this time of
year
i mean there's always you learn you know
different stuff
but just the playoffs is different than
the regular season
you know and game seven is
is tough as gay you know you gotta give
everything today wasn't the result we
wanted
but we'll come back next year thanks
luther appreciate it
tim mcmahon
luca obviously i know you're you care
about winning
not numbers but the numbers you put up
in this series
were ridiculous what do you what do you
think you've been able to prove
uh in this series and even last year in
playoffs
i mean i don't nothing yet you know
we've
been the playoffs twice since i'm there
we lost both times so
nothing yet you know you get paid to win
we didn't do it brad townsend
yeah luke brad townsend dallas 20 news
uh last
year against the clippers you guys never
led in the series
this time you were up 2-0 had three
games at home do you feel like
when you look back at this series you
can look back at it as one that got away
i mean you're gonna look and every
series you lose that
you know you're gonna think like that
you know what we could do better what
uh which games we will win but that's in
the past you know we gotta look forward
in the next season and get the mistakes
out
okay kyle kyle goon southern california
news group
luca i was wondering um at the end there
was paul
george trying to exchange jerseys with
you
and as a follow-up um you know what
what does it mean to you to obviously
you played a longer series at this time
but to lose with the same team
in back-to-back uh the first one yeah we
did i send one
after you know in the locker room and
the second one you know it's tough when
it's the same rival
you obviously don't want to lose again
and like i say you know we we have to
come back next year
uh look at this player so we did good we
did wrong
and just keep keep going from there okay
we'll do two in spanish now
pedro thank you
[Music]
[Music]
here's another fact the 77 points
created by
luca doncic scoring or assisting the
most ever by
player in a game seven according to tim
mcmahon
i believe they call him band mcmahon
that's what they call
you